[Musique]
la transmission dans tous ses états et
bien permettez moi de commencer par
apporter une petite retouche à la
thématique de notre après midi
regardons la transmission dans les états
en fait comment font les grandes
collectivités politique pour transmettre
et ce qui leur paraît indispensable à la
génération future
sur le plan de la mémoire collective
culturel nous savons très bien comment
ça fonctionne ça passe par les
traditions il en a déjà été question les
traditions et les coutumes la tradition
c'est déjà un mot très parlant quand on
regarde de plus près le pilat rose ne
définit comme une manière d'agir ou de
penser transmises justement depuis des
générations
à l'intérieur d'un groupe et pour ce qui
est des méthodes de la transmission de
ses traditions et des coutumes les états
les nations se ressemblent drôlement
c'est comme s'il y avait un kit
d'assemblage identitaire pareil pour
tous dont il suffirait de raccorder les
éléments pour inscrire dans la durée
l'identité du groupe l'élément la
composante la plus importante de ce kit
c'est les lieux de mémoire ils sont
omniprésents dans notre quotidien dans
notre environnement habituel ils sont
mises en valeur dans les musées par les
travaux des historiens
il se cristallise dans des symboles dans
des héros des endroits des événements
considérée comme emblématique
ils ont appris au sein d'un système
d'éducation éducation nationale n'est ce
pas mais aussi dans la famille et à
travers les médias ils s'expriment ils
ont célébré dans les canons de la
littérature des beaux-arts mais aussi du
folklore populaire et finalement ils ont
rappelé avec insistance dans les
tu es le public et dans les
commémorations officielles et tout ça
nous le savons bien nous le vivons au
quotidien
tout ça ça fonctionne à merveille les
états ont réussi à pousser sa la
perfection au niveau national et je
pense que nous avons là un problème nous
n'avons pas un problème sur le plan de
notre identité culturelle
quoique mais nous avons un problème
politique
je m'explique
nous ne sont pas que des animaux
identitaire qui de manière presque
darwinienne sont obsédés à transmettre
leur singularité et leur particularisme
à la génération suivante
nous avons aussi des valeurs politiques
nous avons de manière consciente des
valeurs politiques souvent ces valeurs
qui s'expriment dans des normes des
droits des principes ont été acquis de
haute lutte à travers une longue période
et dans le meilleur des cas
dans le meilleur des cas ces valeurs
politiques sont justement le fruit d'une
émancipation des anciennes traditions et
coutumes justement ils sont issus d'une
rupture avec les anciens régimes de
toutes sortes
quelques exemples ici de normes de
principes de valeurs politiques qui sont
issus du passé qui sont basées fondée
sur le leçons apprises par le passé on a
un problème que ça nous plaise ou non
on a un problème aujourd'hui cette
transmission des valeurs politiques et
les comme la transmission des valeurs
culturelles perfectionner sur l'échelle
nationale nous vivons dans un monde et
le regard sur notre smartphone dans le
journaux le rappelle tous les jours qui
est de plus en plus interdépendant les
groupes sociaux qui le composent devrait
en fait être un peu plus capable de
transcender le conditionnement initiale
sur le plan national devrait être en
mesure d'imaginer des solidarités de
solidarité réelle
au delà de ce carcan qui leur ait légué
par cette transmission
il ya qu'en europe on a lancé ne petite
tentative timide et modeste dans ce sens
a imaginé une coexistence différente de
ces groupes sous la forme d'un genre de
communauté avec des règles plus ou moins
strictes auxquelles se soumettent les
membres de manière volontaire mais pour
y arriver il a fallu trois conditions
préalables indispensables
la première c'était un traumatisme
historique une expérience traumatisante
inégalée c'était celle de la seconde
guerre mondiale
l'effroi devant l'horreur absolue du
carnage et l'effroi devant
l'effondrement de la civilisation qu'on
croyait impossible et qui était
finalement
incarnez dans les camps de concentration
et pour finir dans la bombe atomique et
la destruction totale
déjà il fallait cette expérience
traumatisante
ensuite il a fallu d'une petite fenêtre
d'opportunité ouverte pour un bref
moment mais opportunité saisie par
quelques sommes pas nombreux réseaux lui
de la saisir et surtout très conscient
de la volatilité des choses et de la
capacité remarquable de l'être humain
d'oublier rapidement ce qu'il a appris
du passé
et troisièmement il a fallu la mise en
place très rapide
pendant que la fenêtre était ouverte
d'institutions d'un nouveau type
jean monnet qui était à la fois le
moteur est le cerveau de ce qu'il faut
bien appeler une révolution
civilisationnel il était de manière très
aigu conscient de la volatilité des
leçons apprises par le passé pour lui
les institutions
c'était la clé comme il disait
les expériences tragiques que nous avons
vécu elles nous ont peut être rendu plus
intelligente plus intime plus sage mais
les hommes passent et d'autres prennent
leur place et nous ne pouvons pas leur
transmettre notre expérience personnelle
ce que nous pouvons leur transmettre ce
sont des institutions les institutions
qui durent plus longtemps que les hommes
et si elles sont intelligemment
construite
elles peuvent accumuler et transmettre
la sagesse des générations successives
c'est donc les institutions la clé de la
transmission des valeurs politiques les
institutions politiques
eh bien vous aimez essayer d'en parler à
vos élèves des institutions politiques
ou les mettez en veille en deux minutes
essayer de discuter avec vos concitoyens
dans la pause café tout à l'heure des
institutions politiques eux
vous allez découvrir un océan
d'ignorance sur leur composition leur
fonction les règles qui les régissent
c'est pas gagné
essayez d'en parler un petit peu aux
médias essayez de passionnés de
journalistes pour le sujet des
institutions politiques
eh bien il le considère comme un
somnifère c'est pas gagné non plus les
institutions politiques
quel ennui quelle lenteur
etc l inertie est encore sur le plan
national il ya un peu de piment dans le
clash de ziggo dans l'affrontement des
destins individuels hors norme
la france en sait quelque chose mais sur
le plan européen
c'est doublement plus ennuyeux c'est
doublement plus lent et c'est doublement
plus in her déjà les institutions
européennes
elles sont lointaines elles sont
évidemment déconnecté du citoyen elles
sont lourdement handicapée par la
diversité linguistique qui ralentit tout
encore plus elles sont dotées de
compétences trop étendue à moins que ce
soit de passer de compétences toute
façon elles sont pas dotés des bonnes
compétences 1 et elles sont souffre d'un
déficit démocratique persistant en
matière de nuit d'inertie et de lenteur
on aura du mal à faire mieux que les
institutions européennes c'est évident
n'empêche
n'empêche qu'elle continue à transmettre
indirectement presque inconsciemment une
valeur a prise du passé une conclusion
tirée alors le pari de jean monnet était
celui de mettre en place des
institutions avant que les hommes
n'oublie ce qu'il s'était pourtant juré
de ne plus jamais oublier et aujourd'hui
on dit ce début d'année 2010 est est ce
que on peut dresser un bilan
est-ce qu'on peut oser évaluer ce pari
qui a été pris il ya plus de 65 ans
alors on peut dire que sur le plan de
l'inertie institutionnels nous qui
souhaitons je le pense vivre en
démocratie
l'inertie est une grande qualité j'ai
envie de vous chanter l'éloge de
l'inertie de la lenteur de l'ennui
l'inertie est une énorme qualité elle
est surtout pour la décrocher ma
démocratie
elle est une protection la démocratie
elle est par nature fragile
elle est par nature par définition elle
est exposée au court termisme imposé par
les échéances électorales et elle est
également en proie à la volatilité de
l'opinion publique et donc à la
démagogie de toutes sortes
l'inertie est un formidable rempart
contre l'oubli contre la capacité
toujours étonnante de l'être humain de
refouler et aussi contre les bons vieux
réflexes nationalistes qui sont si
faciles à susciter donc je chante
l'éloge de l'inertie institutionnel sur
le plan européen
est ce que c'est une réussite pour
autant sur le plan du développement je
dirais quantitatif
de ces institutions on peut dire que
l'union européenne d'aujourd'hui
elle a dépassé toutes les espérances que
pouvait éventuellement avoir lé père
fondateur la petite haute autorité du
charbon et de l'acier elle est devenue
une grosse grosse commission comme une
araignée au centre d'une toile
institutionnels complexé et multiforme
c'est impressionnant comme résultat bien
sûr les institutions européennes sont
vivement critiquée dans l'ensemble des
états membres
et je pense souvent à juste titre loin
loin d'être parfaite mais d'isoler
pendant que ça gronde à droite et à
gauche dans les états membres pendant
que les britanniques font leurs valises
et pendant que les académiques les
universitaires des think tanks des
éditorialistes se déchirent pour savoir
s'il faut plus ou moins d'europe pendant
tout ce temps là les institutions dans
cette inertie parfois agaçante mais ô
combien précieuse continue jour après
jour de s'occuper des mille détails de
ce marché unique d'essayer de trouver
des solutions à tous les problèmes que
les états membres leur faute parce
qu'ils trouvent pas de solution humaine
un et à transmettre sans qu'il s'en soit
vraiment conscient cette leçon initial
qui devait être transmises selon lé père
fondateur
moi j'appelle ça une grosse réussite sur
le plan du développement institutionnel
maintenant sur le plan de la solidarité
humaine
c'est peut-être autre chose je dirais
presque que l'union européenne
aujourd'hui c'est une étude de cas assez
précises pour cet énorme difficulté que
les êtres humains du 21e siècle
ressemble quand il s'agit de dépasser le
cadre national dans lequel ils ont été
socialisés dans lequel ils ont un peu
prisonnier
dans lequel ils ont été conditionnés le
grand sociologue norbert elias dans le
dernier ouvrage de sa grande histoire de
la civilisation humaine
il a il y à des décennies déjà mis en
relief ces moments dans la longue
histoire civilisationnel de l'humanité
ces moments hautement problématique où
l'interdépendance et l'intégration
sociale dans une société on atteint déjà
de fait en réalité un niveau supérieur
mais où l'identité culturelle des
individus qui composent ces sociétés
restent fixés scotché à un niveau
inférieur hautement problématique des
moments de grande tension
là il me semble que c'est réflexion
cette théorie est trop longue à
l'adapter à nous décrire la pensée
première décennie du 21e siècle donc sur
le plan de la solidarité humaine
le compte n'y est pas encore tout à fait
maintenant à titre personnel j'ai une
chance énorme je prends le bus numéro 6
de la ligne du réseau angevin
et quand je me rends au travail ou quand
j'en reviens à la proche du collège du
lac de maine il y a toujours une petite
voix féminine sympathique qui mesurent
sur à l'oreille prochain arrêt jean
monnet
honnêtement chaque jour ça m'amuse un
peu voilà l'homme qui a eu l'idée de
faire de la transmission des valeurs à
brice dû passer à travers les
institutions lui même un objet de la
transmission de mémoire c'est assez
amusant presque cocasse et en même temps
malgré les temps qui courent
tous les jours dans mon bus je me force
à y voir une promesse d'avenir
prochain arrêt jean monnet je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]